[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
some big breaking news you're waking up
to this morning about gillane maxwell
we'll bring you that in the next couple
of minutes plus waving goodbye to plan b
covid restrictions but how's the prime
minister got a plan b if pressure from
his own mps leads to a leadership
challenge the health secretary said to
javid on the program shortly we'll also
talk to the shadow chancellor rachel
reeves and we'll speak to the world
health organization to get their take on
plans to end isolation it's thursday the
20th of january
back to plan a kobe restrictions start
lifting in england but criticism from
the world health organization over a
plan to end isolation
don't push us president biden's warning
to russia over ukraine as more military
mass on the border but he admits an
invasion is likely
do i think he'll test
west test the united states and nato
as
significantly as you can yes i think he
will
aid flights from new zealand head for
tonga as more evidence emerges of the
devastation caused by the volcanic
eruption
the newly discovered coral reef off the
coast of tahiti giving hope that there
could be more ecosystems free from the
harm of pollution and global warming
the czech singer against vaccines who
has died after deliberately catching
covid in order to get a vaccine pass
it was really to see whether you could
find the story of a family in a
difficult situation where humor and all
the other coping mechanisms we come up
with to try and deal with difficult
times could speak to other people
we hear from kenneth branagh about his
oscar-tipped new
autobiographical picture belfast
[Music]
also on the programme for you this
morning saving the show going to be
speaking to one of the many understudies
who've been given their big chance on
the stage with barely any notice thanks
to covid
and hitting the great outdoors i'll be
speaking to chris packham about his call
for more young people to get involved
with protecting the environment
[Music]
everybody a very good morning to you a
busy show this morning with plan b rules
on the out but the prime minister for
now still in the health secretary said
you javid on the show very shortly but
first some big breaking news from the
last hour lawyers for the convicted sex
trafficker gillane maxwell have
requested a new trial our correspondent
shingi is down at buckingham palace for
us um hi shin you tell us more
morning kay that's right this just in
that julaine maxwell's lawyers have
filed for a re-trial that news coming
overnight and it's just weeks after she
was found guilty of recruiting underage
girls to be sexually abused by her
former boyfriend jeffrey epstein the
late paedophile financier and she of
course was found guilty on five of six
counts and she faced the prospect of
spending the rest of her life in prison
but soon after the trial emerged this
news that a juror who had been speaking
to various publications members of the
press press had
had been had experienced sexual assault
themselves as a child and used those
experiences to persuade others to
convict maxwell during the trial and
that of course set maxwell's lawyers in
action and earlier this month they wrote
to the new york district judge alison
nathan saying that the issue presents
incontrovertible grounds for a new trial
they have now taken that action
overnight with this letter signed off by
prosecutors requesting that the judge
conde conducts an inquiry into the
juror's conduct she has until february
2nd to respond to that okay lovely thank
you
ministers joined us uh we're pleased to
say um a good morning to you um mr javid
um
obviously we saw you at the news
conference yesterday i just want to play
this world health organization grab for
you and our viewers and then we'll talk
about it here we go
our recommendation is for isolation of
cases isolation and clinical care of
cases to continue because our goal is to
prevent onward spread and also the
quarantining of contacts we support
countries in reducing that time i don't
say abandon it but reducing that time
we're not doing that we're deciding to
get rid of it all together um no no not
quite so what we said yesterday was it
marked a a new chapter in our fight
against the pandemic where we are
returning to plan a so that's what we're
doing and that's because plan b has
worked with the data shows that omicron
is now in retreat and it's worked for a
number of reasons but mainly because it
brought us the time that we wanted to
build our defenses and the best way we
did that across the country were some 15
million people came forward to get
boosted i want to thank each and every
one of them for what they have done to
to help us fight this pandemic and also
all the nhs workers the volunteers and
what they did and it's because of that
that we're now able to remove uh some of
the the rules and restrictions by
returning to plan a so it means that for
example that we're no longer encouraging
people to work from home from thursday
next week there will be no mandatory use
of the nhs covid pass or the use of face
coverings but and turning to that
particular message that we just heard we
do still need to of course remain
cautious prevalences is still high so
we'd continue to recommend caution some
rules still stay in place including the
rule to self-isolate if you are positive
what happens after march
we're not there yet that's a few weeks
away so we're not scrapping the
isolation we will what the prime
minister said yesterday said all these
rules and as i've said a number of times
they remain under review i'm confused
are we scrapping isolation all together
by the end of march or not we will we
will decide as we get closer to march
based on the data at the time all the
decisions that we've made from the start
of this pandemic have been based on the
data and that's what you heard yesterday
because omicron is in retreat because
our plan has worked but as i say there
there is still that because of the need
for continued need for caution there's
something that everyone can still do if
they haven't yet done it which is to get
vaccinated by the end of march or not
we we said we would review those rules
and we would like to see it scrapped by
the end of march but that decision will
be made closer to the time okay in the
press conference yesterday you compared
covid to flu did you really mean to do
that yes
why because it was an example of how we
need to learn to live with covid
hundreds of 1 000 people have died
we have the the impact of covert of
course has been the biggest challenge
this country has seen since the second
world war 150 000 people as you say more
than that now have died have died with
uh with a a you're being positive of
covid and and during that time we have
you know at a great cost to us to many
countries we've seen uh very sadly you
know thousands and thousands of deaths
but we have learned a lot about kobe
given those figures that we both agree
on why is it appropriate to compare it
to flu because we need to learn to live
with it we sadly people die of flu as
well in a bad flu year you can sadly
lose about 20 000 lives but we don't
shut down our entire country and put in
place lots of restrictions to deal with
it we need to continue with our lives
with sensible appropriate and
proportionate measures the one thing we
learned about flu because it's been
around for far far far longer is that we
have annual vaccinations for older
people in particular for children as
well we have good advice we may well
have
some kind of annual vaccination i think
that's where we'll probably end up but
it's really difficult for anyone to say
exactly uh what the
longer term where we will be but one
thing i did also say yesterday is is
covert is not going away it's gonna it's
going to be with us for uh for many many
years perhaps forever and we have to
learn to live with it and what we have
shown mainly because of the vaccines but
also because the new treatments that we
have the antivirals we've got more
anti-virals per head than any other
country in europe the testing
infrastructure that we've built the
biggest testing infrastructure it is
these things that will allow us to live
with kovid absolutely minister but those
people then who were ridiculed for
comparing kovidge to the flow
they shouldn't have been ridiculed
well i don't did you ridicule them i've
never ridiculed them
okay so
several people did shall we well you
think that that was inappropriate to
ridicule people well look i think i
think with the flu i i think it's
if at the start of covid when we had no
vaccines we had no testing
infrastructure we had no treatments
people were comparing it to flu that
would have been wrong of course it would
have been wrong but look where we are
today two years on especially here in
the uk the most boosted country in
europe the most anti-virals per head in
europe the biggest testing
infrastructure in europe it is why we
are the most open country in europe we
are i think i think i think we are
leading europe in in in the transition
from pandemic to endemic and we're
leading the way in showing the world how
you can live with cocaine let's talk
about what happened in the house of
commons yesterday an image of christian
wakeford uh crossing the chamber
defecting in other words will this is
this going to help or hinder the prime
minister
well i i don't see it that way i was sad
to see
i was sad to see christian go it's never
good it's never good for any political
party to see see one of your own uh
leave and defect in that way of course
it's it's not good news but it's it's a
decision for him but i feel sorry for
the people of berry south they voted
they know it conservative i think by
election would be welcome yeah the
people have been if there be one yeah
i'd be very happy with the by-election i
think christian should be happy with the
by-election i think he's supported by
elections in these circumstances in the
past and uh i think given that the
people of berries have rightly voted
conservative in 2019 they wanted to get
brexit done they want to see a strong
economy and and all of that and now
they've got an mp that's changed his
affiliation without their permission why
not give them a say so that's the
younger intake what about those that
have been there for almost longer than
god in the form of david davis let's
remind our viewers what he said
yesterday
i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god go
what sort of blows that
well i i've known david davis for many
years i've got huge respect for him we
don't always agree on everything and
that is one thing i i don't agree with
him on uh the
damaging is it when an elder statesman
who's been there since margaret
thatcher's day stands up and says in the
name of god go it is damaging of course
it is you know if you said to me would i
rather that he didn't get up and elvis
doesn't get up and say something like
that of course i wouldn't want to to see
that that's he's a decision that he's
made that the prime minister has come to
the house of commons last week he's he's
set out
and apologized set out what he
has happened but most importantly i
think is that is he's asked for this
investigation to be done for the time
and space
to be given for it to be completed and
the facts to be established and once
those facts are established the prime
minister will come very quickly back to
parliament and submit himself to
scrutiny so david davis or anyone else
any other member of parliament can ask
them
whatever question they want the other
thing he could do is go for a vote of
confidence now so it won't be that death
by a thousand cuts which david davis has
talked about he can limp on potentially
until the end of the year or party
conference or whatever but if he's so
confident why doesn't he go for that
vote of confidence right now well i
think the the prime minister set out
you clearly that after having rightly
come to the house and apologized that
the next step should be for the facts to
be established i mean i think everyone
would be interested in the facts and and
that is what's so great that yeah right
and that's what i mean
the work that she is doing she should be
given the time and space it's her
investigation no minister should sort of
determine how quickly she does it or who
she speaks or who she doesn't speak to
that's a decision for her but once the
facts are established
then i think we can see how parliament
will respond do you have do you does he
have your complete support he has my
support does he have your complete
support yes he has my complete support i
serve in his cabinet okay um if a
serving prime minister given that if a
serving prime minister breaks the law
does he have to step down
well i don't want to talk about a
hypothetical situation hypothetical
because well i don't was your are you
asking me about this current prime
minister i'm saying does a serving prime
minister if he breaks the law have to
step down well if as a general point the
ministerial code is very clear if any
minister from the prime minister down
breaks the law of of course they
shouldn't continue to serve as a
minister
if this prime minister has broken the
law
should he step down
i what i've just said is a general rule
that applies to everyone there's no
exceptions to that rule so if this prime
minister just to be people yeah look
just to be clear if this prime minister
has broken the law he should step down
look you're very cleverly trying to get
me into a hypothetical situation i knew
you'd say that so i actually looked up
hypothetical and what it means
uh yep an idea or explanation is
something that is based on a few known
facts but that has not yet been proved
to be true or correct we've got a lot of
facts that we can look at as far as this
prime minister is concerned including
photographic evidence of what he got up
to including him admitting that he broke
the rules albeit inadvertently ignorance
is no defense in the law
we don't have the full facts yet that is
that we do he says that he was there but
he didn't know he broke the rules but he
didn't know he was breaking the rules
that's no defense in law look we don't
we don't have the full facts and let me
just say this as well that i completely
understand
why millions and millions of people
across the country from what they have
seen already whether it's on the tv or
in their newspapers or wherever they've
seen it why they are so angered and paid
i completely understand that and i share
that anger and pain i i really do you've
lived it yourself
i've lived it myself and you couldn't
we i'm sure we all have and some of us
in in the in the most difficult of
circumstances you might if i think about
my constituents that couldn't go
to hospital to see dying relatives you
know this is
so this is a very very serious situation
and that is why i do think that the
facts need to be established and you
know and put out there and then people
can come to a judgment i get that but
you know we saw the prime minister with
his hang dog expression earlier on in
the week saying that he was sorry but he
didn't understand the rules had been
broken i put it to you that it doesn't
matter because that is no defense in law
and if a prime minister has broken the
law you've said he should go
well
as i say the the ministry of code
applies to all of us and and it's it's
right the the code
what it says and how you should conduct
yourself but in terms of okay this prime
minister i didn't know but in terms of
this situation we need to establish the
facts and as i say the the prime
minister has come forward he's
apologized he's accepted that mistakes
have happened he's taken full
responsibility and has said he will take
full responsibility for whatever the
sugray report comes out with but the
facts need to be established first he's
even admitted himself he doesn't need
sue grey to tell him he's admitted
himself that he broke them but we don't
we don't we don't have the full facts
and that is
he's pleaded guilty
the the the the report i think is is
going to be absolutely crucial in this
it's being done with someone with the
utmost integrity and respect and
independent civil servant and once that
report is published i think that whether
it's you your viewers parliamentarians
can react to it at that time okay let me
ask it this way then if sue gray decides
that the prime minister misled the house
should he step down that's a
hypothetical situation
what she may or may not decide by the
way i think that would be inappropriate
for any minister because this is an
independent what would be
inappropriate to try and sort of guess
what may or may not
be the outcome of the world he's already
admitted that he broke the rules we've
seen photographic evidence they've been
breaking the rules we've heard about
parties at downing street uh on the eve
of the uh duke of edinburgh's funeral
which is
quite frankly despicable you know all
the evidence is building up and yet
you're still saying let's wait for the
report the prime minister himself has
admitted look we don't know
take take the the the party that took
place on the eve of
of the funeral and it's completely
unacceptable two parties and you know
who knows two parties i'm sure that's
what's been because that's been reported
and the people involved have apologized
that's what happened completely
unacceptable wrong in every way you know
there's there's no excuse for that at
all should people be disciplined and and
represent that of course they should be
but
what happens next we should wait for the
report and for sue to be able to speak
to people that may have gone to the
party may have known about the party may
have any information they can shine on
it let her put that together and present
that information to the british public
and to the parliament and then we can
make a job so we're very cross about
those parties but we won't acknowledge
that the prime minister broke the rules
at another event why why are we
cherry-picking which events that we um
agree with and which we don't i don't
think we are a cherry-picking this this
report can go anywhere sue can look at
anything they're they're so we're we are
rightly we're talking about things that
we know
or have heard about because they've been
reported but the purpose of this report
is to have an independent investigation
that where all the information is
provided she can speak to whoever she
wants and establish that yeah you are in
the runners and riders um let's have a
quick look just before i let you go
we're out of time but your name has been
put forward as one of those who has got
a very distinct chance of running as the
next prime minister of this country what
do you think of that
uh what i think is that there is no
leadership election and this is what all
there is
lots of lots of lots of uh speculation
you like the picture do you think it's
not bad actually yeah it's almost prime
ministerial some might say well they all
look you know look at look at that you
know there's a good good lineup of
talent i would say in the in the party
there and uh so but there is no
leadership election we've got a prime
minister he's getting on with the job
and that's what matters and when there
is do you might fancy it
there is no leadership election good to
talk to you as always thank you very
much for joining us thank you
currently the main favorites are the
chancellor rishi sunak and the foreign
secretary liz trust we saw there but
we're just talking about other cabinet
members and former ministers in the
running and we saw there the home
secretary was there and the health
secretary sajia javid the secretary of
state for levelling up michael gove and
also the former health secretary jeremy
hunt who has taken a lead role in
holding ministers to account throughout
the pandemic
meantime any of the front pages
continuing to focus on the future of the
prime minister the murrah splashes
within the name of god go the call from
the former brexit secretary david davis
urging boris johnson to resign
the financial times suggests the
defection of a conservative mp to labor
has actually rallied tories together
giving mr johnson what it calls a
fragile truce with his party
the telegraph reports that the p
that the pm has vowed to fight on even
if a no-confidence vote is called
and away from number 10 the metro goes
with the decision to end england's plan
b restrictions
saying the legal requirement to
self-isolate if you test positive will
be scrapped within months
and tracy emman apparently has asked for
an artwork that she donated to the
government's collection to be removed
from number 10
that one at the neon sign reading more
passion was installed more than 10 years
ago when david cameron was pm the
article the artist i should say said the
last thing the present government needs
is more passion describing the current
situation as shameful she told the
guardian she was not asking for the
artwork to be given back to her saying
right now there are many more other
places it could go to
still to come on the programme before
you eight o'clock i'm going to be
speaking to the shadow chancellor rachel
reeves about plan b dining street
parties and labour's plan to deal with
the rising cost of living
on the eve of president biden's first
year in the white house a warning for
russia discussing how the last 12 months
have gone for the u.s president with dr
schola and scotty
[Music]
and as england starts to scrap plan b
we'll get reaction from the world health
organization in europe that's at 20 to
8.
you know as president joe biden has
predicted that russia will move in on
ukraine and said it was very important
that nato allies were united in the face
of a potential attack he was speaking at
a news conference to mark the
anniversary of his first year in office
as mark stone reports
the latest images released by the
russian government more russian troops
moving towards ukraine this time into
belarus closer to the ukrainian capital
kiev
president putin is keeping the world
guessing
but in washington president biden
notably is now suggesting that there is
an inevitability about all this
do i think he'll test the west test the
united states and nato as
as
significantly as he can yes i think he
will
my guess is he will move in
he has to do something but then
crucially he appeared to draw a
distinction between invasion and
incursion russia will be held
accountable if it invades and it depends
on what it does it's one thing if it's a
minor incursion and then we end up
having a fight about what to do and not
do etc the seemingly unscripted comments
part of a rare two-hour news conference
marking a year in office will prompt
angst in ukraine and maybe opportunity
in moscow he was offered the chance to
clarify so the question is
if it's a something significantly short
of
uh a significant invasion or not even
significant just major military forces
coming across he offered little his team
later suggesting he was distinguishing
between military and non-military or
paramilitary
what does seem clear from president
biden's comments is that nato is at this
stage still split on what to do about
ukraine and if president putin does
decide to annex another small part of
ukraine well then maybe will he get away
with it without those crippling
sanctions
but on the prospect of a full invasion
the president was stark this is the most
consequential thing that's happened
in the world in terms of war and peace
since world war ii
and that's why the desperate efforts of
diplomacy continue mark stone sky news
in washington
coming up we're going to be talking
about the health secretary telling us
that uh kovid should be treated like the
flu going forward and also there should
be a by-election in berry south i bet
you've got some thoughts on that haven't
you stay tuned for more meantime almost
a week on from the volcanic eruption and
tsunami in tonga the islands are in
desperate need of aid the aid effort is
a long distance one originally shipped
from australia and new zealand a journey
of more than three thousand miles it's
then transported to fiji still 500 miles
from tonga where the aid operation is
being coordinated
and although aid is now starting to
arrive communications is still a major
issue
one of the areas worst affected is
around tonga's capital from fiji here's
greg milam
barely a week ago this was a new beach
resort there is no better illustration
of how tonga's landscape has been
altered
the images from these pacific islands
tell a story of disaster rubble where
there was once homes
streets coated with a layer of volcanic
ash
first we thought it was rain but there
were bits and pieces of rocks
and then after the rocks came down then
we had the dust
and we could not see
while we're driving
marion has been documenting the damage
she's one of the few who's managed to
call out with networks disrupted we need
drinking clean drinking water our
national water supplies is not safe
enough for us to drink
the focus now is on delivering aid
shipments of water tents and food have
set off from australia and new zealand
it's estimated 80 percent of tongans
have been affected by the volcano and
the tsunami that followed
whole villages lost on remote islands
tens of thousands of people in need
[Applause]
stranded by the pandemic in the us netta
was on the phone to her children back
home in tonga when the waves hit for
three days she didn't know if they'd
survived it's a huge
a disaster in tonga it's life on death
matters so
without hearing them um
i was just lost the last few days i
heard the noise and the eruption
happening
and i was the one who was telling them
they should move to a higher ground
and they did
the aid has begun to arrive and tongans
have started to pick up the pieces
there are a few places in the world as
vulnerable to the extreme forces of
nature as the pacific islands these are
resilient communities but for many
there's been nothing like this in their
lifetime and for some the loss has been
total
but one of the few places in the world
to be coveted free is determined the
rush to help doesn't add a new crisis to
the one they're already dealing with
greg milam sky news fiji
greg joining us now live from fiji hi um
greg it's very challenging isn't it such
a long way away from anywhere and
they're desperate for aid
yeah they are the good news though
finally is that some of that aid has now
arrived in the last few hours a military
plane from new zealand uh touched down
on that runway that they spent days
clearing the volcanic ash
from it started unloading what it was
carrying water shelter generators
hygiene supplies uh communication
supplies as well another one from
australia was following on another one
from australia behind that as well so
it's starting to arrive and in in huge
amounts so those supplies some ships
coming as well as you saw in my report
what's key about those shipments and
those planes landing is that they're
what they call no contact missions no
personnel will get off those aircraft
they will just deposit the supplies be
on the ground for about 90 minutes and
leave and the reason is the tongan
government is so concerned about the
spread of covid19 it is pretty much
covered free there they had one case in
october their concern was there would be
a rush of aid aid personnel support
staff and the risk of a a an infection
wave coming ashore and that adding to
the problem that they were already
dealing with and potentially wiping out
communities so we're getting a clearer
picture of what happened in some of
those more remote areas the government
has been evacuating people from those
places where all of the homes were
destroyed and getting them to shelter
and now those supplies as well but the
communications are still broken there is
still a long way to go for the people of
tonga but the aid is starting to arrive
okay for now greg thanks very much
one of the parts of chonga worst hit is
the island of atta um have a look at
these uh images showing the damage done
there following the tsunami and the
volcanic eruption my goodness me this is
what it looked like um
before
that and let's have a quick look at the
comparison of some of the amazing
islands
before the damage just look how
beautiful it is these images sent to us
by um
friends of our producer laura actually
that was the island that they proposed
on and you can see why just how romantic
it is
sadly very different to that oh my
goodness me
that c safe as far as the eye can see um
sadly that was where the tsunami came in
onto the island of atta this weekend
causing
untold damage at the same stage
communication is still very much patchy
we'll get more information and update
you as soon as we can
meantime a look now at some of this
morning's other news making headlines
and a folk singer in the czech republic
has died after deliberately catching
kovid to bypass restrictions on the
unvaccinated hannah hawker said she'd
rather expose herself to the virus than
get the vaccine that's according to her
son
check rules mean proof of vaccination or
recent recovery from covid is needed to
access many venues
the british gunman who took four people
hostage in a texas synagogue told his
brother he was coming home in a body bag
31 year old joseph pushker was remanded
in custody at a special court hearing
last night a second man who was arrested
yesterday has been released without
charge
british airways has joined a number of
airlines in cancelling u.s flights due
to 5g safety concerns there are fears
that the activation of the mobile phone
service near u.s airports on wednesday
could disrupt planes navigation systems
boeing triple sevens are thought to be
particularly at risk of being impacted
a recording of the final call of the
british gunman who took four people
hostage in texas has revealed that he
told his brother i'm coming home as i
said in a body bag malik faisal akram
was shot dead by an fbi swat team 10
hours into the standoff and all four
hostages were released unharmed
an iceberg thought to be more than three
times bigger than london has released
152 billion tons of fresh water into the
ocean when it scraped past the island of
south georgia last year
experts from the university of leeds
have been using satellite images to
track the mega iceberg since it broke
off from the larsen sea ice shelf in
antarctica in 2017 it's releasing more
water apparently every day than six
times the amount of water that is
consumed in the united states
that's quite a fact for you isn't it on
a thursday morning just digest that
meantime kenneth brunner has released
his most personal film to date based on
his own experiences of growing up in
northern ireland in the 60s he spoke to
sky news about what he wanted to achieve
with belfast
it was uh really a long time deciding
whether there was a way in which it
could come out that could reach other
people basically i didn't want to just
be staring at my own navel making a film
like this it wasn't personal therapy it
was really to see whether you could find
the story of a family in a difficult
situation where humor and all the other
coping mechanisms we come up with to try
and deal with difficult times could
speak to other people and this lockdown
promoted that i think because the
introspection and the
feeling unsettled that we we've all
shared really drove me back to that time
i'll be speaking to our arts and
entertainment correspondent katie
spencer in the next hour about belfast
and the other big movies we can expect
to see in this year's oscar nominations
now did you know that today marks
penguin awareness day i know it was in
my calendar
uh scientists and greek peace
campaigners have been conducting
research on the impacts of the climate
crisis on remote antarctic penguin
colonies many is which have never been
surveyed before the antarctic's rapidly
changing climate is severely impacting
penguin penguin colonies according to
the environmental group its last
expedition to the antarctic find that
chinstrap penguin colonies at elephant
island had collapsed some by as much as
in the last 50 years and why don't polar
bears eat penguins
because they can't get the silver paper
off in the last thank you i'm here all
week trying to reveal in the last few
minutes the health secretary sanji javid
has told me that he was very
disappointed by the defection of the
conservative mp christian wakeford to
labor and felt sorry for the people of
bury south and he said a by-election
there would be very welcome
i feel sorry for the people of barry
south they voted
conservative i i think that by-election
would be welcome yeah the people have
been if there'd be one yeah i'd be very
happy with the by-election i think
christian should be happy with the
by-election i think he's supported by
elections in these circumstances in the
past and uh i think given that the
people of berry south rightly voted
conservative in 2019 they wanted to get
brexit done they want to see a strong
economy and and all of that and now
they've got an mp that's changed his
affiliation without their permission why
not give them a say
tamara's here does he look like a future
prime minister then
well who knows when a vacancy might
occur or as boris johnson like to say a
ball might come loose at the back of the
scrum i thought it was interesting that
sergeant javid said to you that when you
asked if the prime minister has his
complete support he said he has my
support i think the cabinet like the
rest of the party are watching and
waiting for what bombshells might be in
sue grey's report uh next week yeah said
that david davis's comments were
damaging
yes i mean
i think the view is that david davis is
not representing a particular tribe of
conservatives he does show that the
discontent with the prime minister
public discontent goes further than
newly elected mps it is the old guard
his former allies over brexit who are
now calling for him to resign whether
others are going to follow david davis
before the report comes out i think many
of them are going to going to hold fire
now until that we do see that report
which we now know will be next week so
perhaps a brief reprieve from the prime
minister but that was an unexpected
salvo from david davis yesterday i think
it would have really hurt particularly
the comparison to neville chamberlain
okay tomorrow we'll see tomorrow's take
at nine o'clock and indeed in the next
hour thank you very much indeed thanks a
lot let's take you to tahiti now in an
extraordinary underwater find a coral
reef has just been discovered in perfect
condition
it's giving scientists hope that there
could be more marine ecosystems that
have not been damaged by pollution and
global warming here's katie barnfield
a discovery as beautiful as it is
hopeful
this huge reef filled with rose-shaped
corals was found by scientists off the
coast of tahiti
unusually it's in pristine condition
unharmed by pollution or people
well it's exciting because it's uh it's
a healthy reef and
you know
if you look at the stories it's it's
quite
quite going the opposite we have lost
about half of our coral reefs in the
last 70 years and it's really the stuff
that makes you dream and it makes you
really understand the beauty and the
treasure of the
marine environment in the ocean
the reef was discovered by a team of
unesco scientists using state-of-the-art
diving equipment that allowed them to
stay deeper for longer periods
after 200 hours of diving they measured
the reef at three kilometers long and
stretching down to 70 meters below sea
level
that makes it one of the world's largest
at this depth and raises the prospect of
more reefs waiting to be found
more dives are planned in the coming
months to study the reef and the marine
life that has made it their home
but its discovery shows how little we
still know about our underwater world
katie barnfield sky news
[Music]
wow magical joe biden entered the white
house a year ago today 20th of january
it's not been an easy 12 months for the
u.s president with a coveted pandemic a
humiliating withdrawal from afghanistan
and a sinking approval rating so how
should we mark his records so far and
does donald trump have any chance of
winning back the job joining us now to
discuss it in more detail dr scholler
and scotty are with us hello ladies it's
always great to have you both together
um
scotty let's go to you first of all um
it's been a challenging 12 months for mr
biden what were the pluses from his
presidency
well if you listened to president
biden's speech today there was lots
there was a lot of great things that
president biden had accomplished this
year which was very odd considering
we're having the highest inflation
united states in 39 years we have oil
prices gas prices at a seven year high
our grocery shelves are completely
almost empty in
from california to washington dc and
speaking of dc we had the least amount
of freedom the most amount of
restrictions on 13 year olds 14
year-olds and 15 year olds who can't
even go in and buy a hamburger and get
out of the rain in most major cities
on top of that the coronavirus numbers
over the past year are the highest that
they've ever been so a lot of the same
reasons which got donald trump fired a
year ago are not only still in existence
today but have seen a rapid rapid
increase in the problems and americans
right now are very fed up with it and
that was very obvious and yet today for
two hours we saw this victory lap uh
taken by the president biden that most
people even by the end of it were
shaking their head going it's time for
him to give it up
um dr scholar
well scotty happy new year to you but
i'm sure you're not surprised that i'm
really not going to agree with some of
the comments you just made i think the
reality is this that body in his speech
came across as engaging empathetic he
was strong and he was articulate right
as you would expect from any leader what
was definitely different
i mean this is to um scotty's point is
donald trump was he was got rid of
because he was a bad leader because he
was a liar and he had all kinds of bad
qualities when you look at biden's first
year let us look at the fact that yes he
had a successful vaccine rollout that
the economy under him he had like a
greater number of job creation than
donald trump did he had 6.3 million
donald trump lost over 509 million let's
look at the fact of his covet relief
bill and the work that that did and the
major bipartisan infrastructure package
the list goes on but i am not blind to
the challenges that he faced when he
took on the office i am not blind to the
fact that he has a whole lot more work
to do but he set the building blocks to
have a successful second year and yes
donald trump is trying to make his way
back and let's understand this the
republicans are doing everything to make
that possible with their voter
suppression
election reception all they are doing is
trying to set the path for donald trump
to come back they even they as you know
the private women of their rights to
abortion and so many other things and we
know that this is primarily how they try
to get donald trump back especially with
the narrative around the election and on
undermining faith in the democratic
democracy so as far as i'm concerned i
think his first years each was a good
one but he has a whole lot more work to
do he did seem to slip up i don't know
um it'd be interesting to think what you
two ladies have to say about this
starting with you scotty talked about a
minor incursion by uh russia into uh the
ukraine and what reaction there might be
it was a minor incursion given the way
the world is looking at that at the
moment isn't that an oxymoron
well considering at this point you're
seeing that right now you know donald
trump was criticized for being best
friends with putin and yet in this case
you had joe biden admit hey putin can go
in and take a part of ukraine whether
that's his plans or not it doesn't
matter what joe biden said in that line
was hey he can do it and we're not going
to do anything about it we're not going
to if one country invades another it's
okay it's a part of it that was a sign
of a weakness right there that we all
know that if donald trump would have
made that same comment we would be
having that discussion today but once
again and this is a great thing i'll
give it to shola we look at the same
glass and one's half full one's half
empty depending on who's actually
drinking out of that class that's kind
of how we that's how americans are
looking at this issue so when you're
looking at world but you cannot
take this past year and you look at what
happened in afghanistan and just the
absolute horrible withdrawal and the
chaos that covered it and not realize
that for some reason joe biden is right
now looking for a way to get america
back involved again to feed the largest
military budget that we've ever had and
he's going to use any example possible
to pay off his cronies here in his
campaign and guess what ukraine is right
now the best option
okay so i think we need to flip your
your script right there first of all i
am more than capable which i have not
seen you do scotty i'm more than capable
of calling biden out and i think his
response you haven't yet
yeah but i think his response to russia
and ukraine yesterday made no sense he
did not get to his point until the end
of what he was trying to say of course
so when he said minor incursion i even
went huh what are you talking about
there should be he russia should not
even be allowed to have a minor culture
but at the end of his point what he was
trying to say was it depends on what
russia does and of course we know that
white house then came back with
clarification i think without a doubt
biden has to understand he needs to be
more careful with how he articulates
this point and let me just also address
this okay the whole thing about
afghanistan and the way um america
pulled out again let me remind you the
message from afghanistan started with
donald trump and yes um biden has fought
some conservation that could have done a
better job with the pull-out but the
reality is that america had signed up to
pull it out
when they did so there's a whole lot of
way to go around he could have done
better with the actual pull-out
but here's the thing it actually started
20 years ago and that's what i think the
problem is with this administration 20
years ago america should not have gotten
her nose in an area that had nothing to
do with her we have this thing called
the monroe doctrine here in north
america that for some reason many of our
politicians and at this point joe biden
seems to ignore and so looking for a way
to get involved whether it's with any
with russia anything in europe to get
involved in something that has nothing
to do with u.s interests when there's so
many issues here at home to keep him
busy it shows it's quite a distraction
that he's trying to do uh to maybe his
abysmal record of what's going on in the
united states right now we don't have
groceries in our shelf show that there
is more freedom in the uk
than the united states there's something
wrong with that and it's under this
leadership very very quick response
doctor because we are out of time very
quickly
so scotty that's not true when you talk
about the shells being empty that's not
true again that's good
they are you have
with the world on that severe global
supply the united states had more than
90 percent of its supplies in many shops
i just got back from i just got back
from one of your states and there was no
lag anywhere not in any single snow
though
that is true you make a very good point
there the the shelves are empty in lots
of uh countries around the world but
it's a talking point for next time
ladies it's great to see you both back
together again hopefully we'll see you
maybe next week i do hope so thank you
thank you
thanks a lot let's go back to kovid
restrictions which are to be eased in
england with boris johnson saying cases
are falling and the omicron wave has
peaked nationally joining us is dr
richard peabody who leads the laboratory
task force for high threat pathogens at
the world health organization's regional
office for europe which is quite a title
doctor if you don't mind me i'll just
call you doctor what do you think about
the suggestions that we're going to
scrap most of our regulations
yeah thanks very much for the
opportunity to speak this morning so um
yeah i'm uh
the high threat pathogen lead here in uh
in copenhagen and well the current
situation in europe actually is
is is a worry i think you know we can't
afford to be complacent now we are
facing across the region
actually a huge wave of of omicron which
is now
spreading across the countries of of the
region from west to east
and that is resulting in very large
numbers of infections
in the countries of
of europe we had over 8 million
cases reported last week a huge number
and of course we know many of those uh
are less severe but that did result in
over 20 000 deaths in the past past week
across the countries of europe so this
remains a
a serious infection we still are in a
pandemic
and
you know
we do need to still take this seriously
and important to highlight that as this
wave moves further east it's moving into
countries where
vaccine uptake in vulnerable populations
is much lower than in countries such as
the uk so
we i think there's still some some rocky
road ahead for um many countries in in
europe
i wonder if i could put this to you
doctor i did uh mention it to the health
secretary i don't know if you heard him
speaking on the programme in the last
hour and he was saying that we it it's
absolutely reasonable to compare kovid
to the flu now would you agree
i don't agree um you know we're not at
that
point yet um
omicron sarsko v2 is a different
infection it still can be a very serious
infection in those who
are unprotected those are unvaccinated
um and you know i'd really like to
reinforce the message that if
if you're not vaccinated if you've not
completed your course of vaccination
really important
that uh that you do get it because it it
will protect you against serious
disease against hospitalization against
against death um
we are clearly moving into a different
phase of the pandemic you know
we have to sort of celebrate the success
of the vaccine program and
the rollout in many countries and the
protection of the population but we're
still not
yet at the end of the road as far as the
pandemic is concerned
okay doctor it's good to talk to you
thank you for taking the time to join us
in copenhagen this morning thank you
it's a pleasure pleasure
let's talk more about the p the pm
should we pm cues yesterday and what we
heard um from david davies an elder
statesman of the conservative party
saying in the name of god go uh let's
bring in david gork former conservative
justice secretary of course um thanks
for joining us um
we're waiting for sue gray's report
aren't we he just needs to sit tight for
now
i think that's right um and i think from
the perspective of
if you're a conservative mp um wanting
to remove the prime minister there are
probably good reasons for waiting
for the su grey report if you go before
then then you run the risk of prejudging
that report the prime minister can just
defend himself and saying look you know
wait for sue gray and it'll all be clear
um then then we'll get the sue gray
reports and um you know whether she can
really exonerate the prime minister and
whether the prime minister when he comes
to the house of commons and makes a
statement can give clear answers
um i think remains to be seen because
you know it's really quite a difficult
position for him and it's it's not
really credible for him to say for
example that the meeting on the
the drinks party on the 20th of may was
a work event i don't think anyone really
believes that and the idea that it's not
really his fault and someone should have
told him what the regulations were also
stretchers uh credulity so so i i i
think um at this point
it would be a surprise if 54 letters
were reached before the sugray report
but after that i think it'll be you know
there's certainly a moment of risk for
it
um given that you were former justice
secretary and and what you've just
illustrated about the prime minister
saying i was there but somebody should
have told me that i was breaking the
rules as justice former justice
secretary am i not right and saying with
my central law for journalists that
ignorance is no defense in the law
yes that's right that's right but it's
also i mean bizarre
in the circumstances of the prime
minister to make that argument you when
it comes to
any significant policy decision that a
minister would make you know he or she
would receive a written submission
uh there would be a meeting where you
could question officials and your policy
advisors
asked lots of hard questions you know
what are the hard cases what are the
boundary issues how do these regulations
work what's the decision that i'm making
and then and then you make that decision
and you should make that decision having
made a great deal of thought
the idea that the prime minister could
make decisions about what the lockdown
rules were
and then
not know what they were is is remarkable
particularly when you go back to the
20th of may and those rules were very
simple i mean in broad terms if you if
you had to ask the question as to
whether you were allowed to do it the
answer was no
um so so this idea that you know it was
all very complicated and you know i
hadn't understood it and no one had
warned me
um is is a little difficult to believe
um okay talk to me about
whether you might return to the
conservative party or whether you'd like
to return to the conservative party um
if boris johnson was no longer leader
well obviously i do have my difficulties
with boris johnson but um i mean i would
wait to see what happened with the
conservative party but i suspect not i
suspect the conservative party is
heading in a particular direction that
it probably is over the long term
becoming more populist and more
nationalist i hope i'm wrong about that
and i hope whoever succeeds boris
johnson whenever that might be
uh will take the conservative party in a
in a different
direction and perhaps return it to some
of its uh traditions
but you know i i will certainly
watch with interest but i i'm at this
point i'm not that optimistic that the
conservative party for example will take
a realistic view as to what our
relationship with the european union
needs to be we've left the european
union but we need a constructive
relationship with the eu um and you know
i'm not seeing very much sign that
there's an appetite for that from within
the conservative party
um if not boris johnson then whom do you
think who do you think
is the most likely people from the
runners and riders that we've been
talking about today that might uh lead
the party going forward and indeed the
country
i think the most likely winner will be
would be rishi sunak he
is popular with the parliamentary party
and he is popular according to all the
polls with the general public
so that obviously puts him in a very
good position we don't know for sure how
popular it is with the
uh party membership i mean some of the
polling of party membership suggests
that he is favorite some of it suggests
that liz trusts um is is very popular as
well so amongst the party membership i i
would think it would be between rishi
sunak and and liz trust
um and um i i would i would assume that
rishi would be the favorite but you know
there are other candidates who may well
come forward you know jeremy hunt i
think brings a great deal of experience
i think he hasn't had a good pandemic
being very effective as a chair of the
health and social care select committee
uh uh so so he is a credible candidate
as as well but yeah i i think it has to
be said that rishi sunak starts this
campaign if if that's what's about to
happen um is very much the firm favorite
okay and how long do you think the prime
minister has left we're writing him off
aren't we i mean but he is the comeback
kid he's as i said yesterday he's had
more comebacks than frank sinatra
yeah there's no certainty about this and
he has escaped from scrapes before but i
think he is in deep trouble um and uh
you know whether it's after the sugray
report or after the may local elections
which will likely be very bad for the
conservatives uh i i think his position
is is is now really very difficult
good to talk to you um thanks very much
indeed for taking the time hopefully
we'll speak to you again can we talk to
you again next week after we've got the
report out
by all means
ah fantastic we'll make contact with you
thank you
thanks again
thanks a lot quick look at some of the
best pictures making the morning papers
let's end on and up should we the daily
mail has a spread of a bunch of bananas
have a look but with beautiful portraits
carved into them that is what they are
looking like that's amazing i'm going to
get up and show you some more the times
has a picture of an historic 79 year old
spitfire there we go wow look at that
uh with nearly all its original parts a
bit like me that's on sale and it's
estimated to go for four and a half
million pounds i think i'm really funny
today if nobody else does and strictly
come enhancing blackpool's world famous
ballroom has undergone a three-week
spruce up ahead of reopening on saturday
what a great i used to waltz around
there standing on top of my daddy's feet
when i was a little girl
takes me back uh pop fiction finally the
sun has these shots of a picture house
in manchester that allows dogs to enjoy
a film
with their owners that's absolutely
fantastic kovid is like the flu really
more on that to come
[Music]